bonjour jean paul chang merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
le secrétaire d'état américain mike
pompéo a donc annoncé l'annulation des
restrictions de longue date un sur la
façon dont les diplomates américains et
autres ont des contacts avec leurs
homologues à taïwan le gouvernement
chinois qui soutient que la chine
continentale et taiwan font partie d'une
seule chine et même énième pied de nez
de l'administration trump à la chine
avant de quitter la maison blanche
oui en tout cas c'est un axe aussi
radicale parce que c'est une louche qui
a été franchi donc les chinois c'est
vraiment la paix qu ainsi que dans les
11 derniers jours du pouvoir en tout cas
c'est aussi une invitation au ball-trap
a probablement donné en exemple à
d'autres pays quoi pour faire les deux
choses
ce qui est des petits mois rend au pk
extrêmement et d'irriter ses si cécile
temps s'est il faut attendre maintenant
que le anisation byden se met en place
confiant ou infirmes à filament ces
mesures de dernière minute prise par la
nasa sont reines qui aura eu le mérite
avec au moins constante dans sa
politique d'hostilité vis-à-vis de pékin
justement le 20 janvier joe biden sera
investi 46e président des états unis
quelles seront les liens washington
pékin avec cette nouvelle administration
escalade verbale ou a contrario
apaisement des relations
je pense que ça swingue hayden ne se
montra un peu plus prudente que talent
est ce parce que y apparaît gapas cette
pression des derniers jours de
démonstrations donc il faut faire tout
ce qu'on a envie de faire
donc je pense que là une soixante bailon
fois que tu es une évaluation que
différentes des conséquences et des
conséquences probables ce qui a été fait
pendant quatre ans vise à quelqu'un ça
ne veut pas dire que dans un
rapprochement ou un apaisement rapide
avec pékin parce que il faut savoir que
l'opinion publique américaine et
l'opinion d'une partie de l'élite
démocrate est extrêmement remonté contre
pékin aussi les nouvelles règles mises
en place par le gouvernement chinoises
qu'elles suffiront pour contrer les lois
et les sanctions américaines
alors en fait il s'agit simplement d'un
décret du ministère de du commerce
chinois qui met en place les règles et
les modalités à suivre pour les
entreprises ou les individus vivent les
citoyens chinois qui ont à souffrir de
l'application excessive des extraits
l'extra territorialité des lois
américaines dans un pays tiers
par exemple penser des choses qui
existent les textes qui existent aussi
pour l'union européenne que le canada
pour le mexique
et chacun de ces pays où ces régions ont
des textes qui prévoient comment va se
comporter les entreprises lorsqu'elles
sont frappés dans des pays tiers par
l'extension de l'application de la loi
américaine
c'était le cas on s'en souvient par
exemple pour l'union européenne en ce
qui concerne les entreprises européennes
travaillant avec l'iran or les chinois
n'avaient rien tout ça il y avait un
vide juridique en de plus en plus les
entreprises chinoises ou des citoyens
chinois sont assujettis à des sanctions
dans des pays tiers ont ramené
conséquence à la pression américaine
cirque euro menace éventuellement des
entreprises européennes de sanction si
s'il traite avec entre les choix sur une
liste noire américaine
à ce moment là vient uniquement il y
avait un avis déposé
les chinois sont le fait de mettre en
place tout un dispositif qui peut
qu'aider les modalités qui prévoit
éventuellement aussi des mesures de
judiciaire à savoir que l'hyper
organisation judiciaire au niveau des
communes aux chinois contre des
entreprises étrangères ou des pays
étrangers qui appliquerait à music man
l'extraterritorialité d'un loi
américaine c'est une façon de rassurer
plusieurs produits chinois c'est le
donner un cadre pour éventuellement se
déforme ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que pékin se méfie
tout de même de joe biden quant à la
guerre commerciale
pékin et washington on sait que ces deux
garçons martial elle a duré tout le long
du mandat de donald trump sûr parce
qu'il ya quand même une série de mesures
qui ont été prises déjà par le
département américain du commerce
et certes certaines actions ne sont pas
encore mises en oeuvre mais on se pose
beaucoup de questions sur qui la suite
des événements est ce que la stratégie
américaine de toute façon quel que soit
l'administration et de limiter l'action
des entreprises chinoises
le développement des autres villes
chinoises et donc d'apporter un maximum
d entraves aux quelque 1 effectivement
la chine le gouvernement chinois se
prépare et entre autres le par la mise
en place ses personnages juridique qui
n'existaient pas merci jean paul chang
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste et
spécialiste de la chine